did you feel as though you might need to
hide who you are to become a
professional footballer yeah i think so
obviously because there's no one out
felt like i do need to hide it and
wait until i've retired to maybe come
out but i just knew that that was just
such a long time of just lying and not
being able to have what i want why do
you think there is this big taboo
in male professional football about
being gay
i think it comes down with a lot of
footballers want to be known as like
masculinity and i think
being gay a lot of people use it as
being weak are you worried about
homophobia moving forward from fans
and on social media you know i think it
is an easy thing for people to target
you know i'm kind of just learning that
you know
like say i'm playing football on the
field and they're shouting off at me you
know you're paying to watch me play
football and i'm living my life and i'm
making money from it so shout out what
you want it's not going to make a
difference you know